welcome to this video playing team glut
services I keep forgetting the precise
name jakub van glute 21 years old now
I'm never sure about those kind of those
kind of lines because um you never know
when they wrote them down is pretty
young pretty young a grandmaster from
Denmark okay i recently had a Bishop f4
Queens gambit against him so going to
mix it up a bit with the Bishop g5 line
not sure what is playing actually what
what kind of line Oh a very classical
one night bd7 that's it's really not bad
I mean this is the really really old
stuff from the days of Kappa Blanca and
11 alykhan hmm it's it's totally okay I
mean there is no reason to not play it
besides the only thing that you can
maybe argue said it is a bit
old-fashioned that it's not a very
active way to play but there is no
objective there's nothing wrong with it
okay well he has played a six in this in
the structure how to play here maybe I
should try to get for this pillsbury
information maybe I get this in not sure
if he has any better move than in night
move here he it seems he hasn't and I
was thinking 95 now but he still has an
ID for this typical maneuver but still
I'm basically a move up here as a six is
not very useful so I'm going to going to
go with that let's let's see what should
I do now Queen takes I guess and I can
take
I wonder if i take and play efore isn't
this interesting maybe using no account
you can take rock TX and queen to d7 I
see and if i take
hmm tricky I was thinking at four maybe
the idea is to play f5 here cutting of
his Bishop five is a huge threat he has
to do something about it yeah he's doing
something about it but I'm not sure that
this is helping him very much what he's
doing is he's trying to free up the h5
f7 the root for his bishop ok I'm going
to play that I'm already somewhat behind
on the clock which is not good news
transferring the Queen to f4 which is a
good place for it
it's not doing anything on f2 anymore
yeah but how do i how do I make any
progress in this position not easy I
mean it's clear that a little bit more
active but it's hard to determine a plan
here okay take 24 maybe well maybe not
sure about it but and switch to an IQ p
what he is what he has now is 97 to e5
as a possible way to play he definitely
does not want to trade on d4 this is
just better for wide and he avoided that
quite expectedly okay um I'm going to
try to transfer the bishop to f3 getting
some pressure against the pawn maybe see
to be three would have been better maybe
and Joey bishop f3
yeah g4 is a move I don't want to play
definitely not huh
how to avoid them I mean I'd like to get
the bishop to have three job the e3 porn
is a huge problem it really is my rook
takes and be to hang so that that's not
easy when he can take with the rook
especially with the rook is a problem
check I wasn't so afraid of of that but
maybe it's still it's still good for
black guy he has got 95 now okay didn't
play that ok I wanted to prepare this
move that I can go to g2 my ideas play
time one in the smooth and after the
capture only six preventing d4 that's
very important now I don't see how is
protecting d5 night c4 I just take
Bishop d5 is some something like a
self-penned but I can take with this
easily if he moves the rook I take the
night so I am I'm the worst is
definitely over here I believe but it's
still not easy I should have played you
for sure I still should have played g5
in this position and then he's got okay
it's not the end of the world as I'm
threatening e7 always he's overlooking
that that's it sets it's very nice Jack
and winning yeah sometimes the simple
tricks do to win I was in really bad
shape in this game black resigns yeah I
don't really know what what exactly was
wrong here I mean around here I like my
position it should be somewhat better
for white nothing brilliant but somewhat
know maybe not i'm not sure i'm not sure
maybe this was a bit too slow he
definitely has counter play I don't know
maybe I need to play some something more
forcefully I like
like let's say yeah you for move like
that I don't know maybe hmm maybe this
isn't so bad it's just just a matter of
precision for instance this maybe maybe
I should go here actually to go to a to
getting this pressure increased and this
way I'm also keeping f5 under protection
that's better here it started to get if
he and now I don't know this is
definitely good for black what I do
think I ever hear check that somewhere
else he needs an improvement yeah a 95
is excellent he didn't do that and after
some moves here this is I don't know ah
here its tactics yeah again he should
just take this of course because after
the capture he can move the king this is
the kind of simple tactic that very
often decides a game if he is seeing
that he probably just wins it but he
didn't and now the the worst is over for
me I mean I'm still in some trouble
because the e6 porn is weak but I was
really worse before yeah yeah it's still
a winner he only has to avoid this is
this simple trick IAM night f4 even this
is very simple yeah he wasn't paying any
attention anymore night a voice is very
simple instead he he blundered line with
this yeah very lucky win very lucky win
okay thanks for watching